[موسيقى]
صافي
نعم
العرابة التي افتتحناها في الحادي والعشرين
[موسيقى]
ليس
بهذه الطريقة يتيح لك القيام بذلك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نحن سوف
حسنًا ، هذا كثير قليل جدًا
[موسيقى]
اليوم
سباق القوارب
[موسيقى]
أوه
لأن الموسيقي
[موسيقى]
في المحاولة
يجب ان يملك
[موسيقى]
هو المكان الذي يجب أن أرسل فيه تلك الخاصة بهم
المشاكل التي كنت
ليأتي
[موسيقى]
و
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مواسم
أنا
[موسيقى]
الأيام
كيف قلت
[موسيقى]
قل وداعا بعناية كيف تشعر
الشهية
[موسيقى]
قبل الوقت
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وأكثر من ذلك بقليل
أنا
[موسيقى]
أوه
تنويه
[موسيقى]
أنت
انظر داخل نموذج بالحجم الطبيعي لشهر واحد
و
[موسيقى]
و هكذا
أنماط مختلفة
وكل شخص
[موسيقى]
زوما
م
[موسيقى]
أنا
هل حقا
إذا تم الانتهاء منه
من مترو الانفاق
انتهى مارك جريخت من تدمير
عالم سعيد ومفتوح طريقه الوحيد
الجزء د
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]